this is a really fast quickly growing
movement
among millennials something like 10
identify as
a third gender so that's a lot of people
and
i would be totally on board with people
identifying however they want if it
didn't also include
things like medical interventions like
double mastectomies
taking testosterone testosterone in a
lot of cases and in a lot of cases
i think these are just young gay people
who
are struggling with that
do you think it's starting the sort of
hysterical nature of this
of what you just described like you have
to be attracted to me if this and all of
those things do you think it's starting
to backfire on them because i think
most people even even conservatives that
sort of as you alluded to earlier
they don't they don't sort of love
talking about these topics i don't know
a lot of conservatives that don't want
trans people
i don't know any conservatives actually
that don't want trans people to be
treated equally under the law or
something
or something like that but i do sense
that there is a real
backlash now where the movement has gone
so far
that people are just like you know what
forget this whole thing like the whole
thing is evil
and that's what i'm worried about
because when we group these letters
together
i can i can sort of understand the
people that are frustrated like that
i could see that i would where it really
concerns me is where we are going to be
going what the next
step is going to be in terms of what the
outcome is going to be and so we're
seeing also this growing trend of
non-binary people identifying as
non-binary and again that
can be for some people a way of coping
with the fact that they are gay or
lesbian
and they are not yet able to accept that
about themselves
or because it is easier to not identify
as gay in society because there is still
homophobia
and so can you just explain what
non-binary is just for
for someone that might not know yes so
it's people who
identify as a third gender so they may
say they're both genders or neither
and so non-binary gender fluid gender
neutral
genderqueer even though queer is
considered by some people's to be a slur
against gay people i don't tend to like
to use word queer
um so yeah so this is a really
fast quickly growing movement um among
millennials something like 10 identify
as
a third gender so that's a lot of people
and i would be totally on board with
people identifying however they want if
it didn't also include
things like medical interventions like
double mastectomies
taking testosterone testosterone in a
lot of cases and in a lot of cases
i think these are just young gay people
who are
struggling with that and we should offer
them support instead of
having them undergo these interventions
right so that's what i think is so
interesting about this because i think
the average person wants
most people to live and let live and
however you identify
that's fine as long as you're not you
know forcing someone to do something
i think what what happens then is this
next version where it's like
you can be you can say you're non-binary
and if you feel that way then
so be it but what happens is then they
won't let you accept
biology so now it seems like this is now
in
direct conflict with biology and i think
a lot of people are sort of
they're like no that's the last line
here that we're just not going to give
on
do you think that's fair to say right
and again i like you i have no issue
with people how they want to identify
just don't tell me that that's what the
scientific research
shows because when you start denying
science that doesn't help anyone
and the truth is eventually going to
come out so with regards to gender
gender is binary because for 99
of us our gender is our biological sex
of course there are intersex people and
they're trans people for whom this
doesn't necessarily apply
but that's not to say that gender is a
spectrum or that
it's however you want it you don't you
don't choose your gender you know this
is what they're teaching in education
now that
that people choose their gender and i
think it's really harmful
to put all this misinformation out there
especially in the case of
someone who is identifying this way for
reasons that may come from you know
their own internal struggles maybe they
have other mental health issues
and they're not we're not being able to
talk about that i think if we could have
the conversation and
someone could say yes i've considered
all these things
but i still feel i would like to have a
double mastectomy and
that would be better for me even though
a lot of these individuals are really
young when they're doing this
then i wouldn't have so much of a
problem but we can't even have the
conversation if you even try to bring it
up it's considered hateful even to say
that there are two genders it's
considered transphobic now
right so what so all right
some people watching this are going to
clip it and show say that you're
transphobic and i'm a self-hating gay
and all all the usual stuff so to
counter that
and you write about this in the book can
you just sort of give me the
the road map if there was a young person
six years old that really felt that
you know they were they were physically
a boy but they identified as a girl
what do you think a healthy road map
would be as opposed to
the unhealthy road map that you're
talking about that's just transitioning
them
at such a younger age i would say to
the parents especially just to love your
child unconditionally
it doesn't matter what toys they want to
play with what they want to drink
how they want to dress who their friends
are anything like that let if this
little boy wants to wear makeup and
dresses
and play with his girlfriends and that
should be totally fine and conversely if
you have a little boy who is male
typical
i think that's also fine i think among
especially woke
parents they don't want their children
to be gender typical nowadays which
is is just so bizarre so it's it's like
the inverse of what it used to be that
parents didn't want their kids playing
with gender atypical toys because
they're afraid their kids are going to
grow up to be gay and now it's that they
don't want them playing with gender
typical toys because they think that's
going to limit their growth as
an adult so yeah just leave him alone
and if he says he wants to be the
opposite sex
see how he feels at puberty right so
then what what is
what does that look like so now okay so
the child they they love them they
they let them play with whatever they
want be friends with whatever whoever
they want to wear whatever they want etc
now now puberty comes along then then
where are you at
well what would normally happen say in
what's been documented in the research
literature is
children who are gender dysphoric once
they start having crushes on
their peers once they start you know
growing into their bodies a lot of them
realize oh this is actually pretty great
i like my body
and i'm happy the ones who remain
dysphoric and
persist i would recommend seeing a
mental health professional or even
even prior to that point if if the
child's gender dysphoria is quite
severe and debilitating the issue though
is that nowadays
the vast vast majority of mental health
professionals who work with gender
dysphoric children
and even gender dysphoric adults are
i don't want to say that they're
compromised but definitely ideology is
playing a huge role in terms of how they
practice
because they cannot by law
say anything other than yes if you want
to transition i'll help you i'll help to
facilitate
this because they're going to be accused
of commit of practicing conversion
therapy
even though conversion therapy for
gender identity does not exist
there's a difference between conversion
therapy for sexual orientation which as
we talked about last time is not
effective it should not be done there's
no such thing as conversion therapy for
gender identity because
young children who identify as the
opposite sex again
their gender is i don't use the word
fluid but it's more flexible because
they haven't fully developed yet
so with development they're more likely
to feel differently
right all right so wait just to
completely clear that up and we did go
into the first part or the second part
uh last time so gender or conversion
therapy for gay people meaning to take a
young gay boy and to
do whatever version of conversion
therapy there is
uh there's just no evidence that that
actually works what you're saying here
is
if uh if a therapist was dealing with a
young person who identified as the other
gender
that in essence they sort of have to
go with it because what what is it that
they would lose their license or
or is there because it's not conversion
at that point at some level right like
what what
what are or you think it's just this the
pressure of being a therapist
that they'll they'll be ostracized it's
the climate it's that other
professionals will ostracize them it's
because they do run the risk of then
losing their license because
organizations will come after them and
say you are not practicing according to
what the standards are supposed to be
that you'll also have activists coming
after them trying to ruin their
reputation and their livelihood
and so what has happened is i know
colleagues who have told me that
anyone who does not feel right about
this they are
leaving the field they will not see
patients with gender dysphoria period
because they just they don't feel right
and they can't do their job properly if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about academia
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our academia playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist they're all right
over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell